توقعتكم بكل خير هذا موجز الاخبار من
الجزيره هاجم مستوطنون متطرفون منازل عدد
من الفلسطينيين في قريه بورين جنوب نابلس
وقال مسؤول ملف الاستيطان في شمال الضفه
الغربيه انها عشرات المستوطنين هاجموا
منازل الاهالي في القريه واكدت مصادر طبيه
فلسطينيه عدم وقوع اصابات خلال تلك
الاعتداءات
ايتواصلوا حصار الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لقضيه
حوار جنوبيه نابلس أقد دان وفد من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي الاعتداءات على بلدات
حواره وزعتره وبورين التي ارتكبها
المستوطنونه ودعا الى محاسبه مرتكبيها
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره قال الامين العام
للام المتحده انطونيو لا بديل عن حل
الدولتين واضاف ان على المجتمع الدولي
التحرك بقوه لضمان ان يحظى القانون الدولي
بالاحترام
قال المفوض السامي لحقوق الانسان ان الوضع
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله ماساه
بالنسبه للشعب الفلسطيني واضاف ان قوته هي
الامن الاسرائيليه استخدمت القوه المميته
ضد الفلسطينيين بشكل متكرر
قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي انه اكد
لرئيسه هيئه الاركان الامريكيه مارك ميلي
الذي يزور اسرائيل اهميه استمرار العمل
لمنع ايران من امتلاك اسلحه نوويه وكانت
وزاره الدفاع الاسرائيليه قد قالت لنا
رئيس هيئه الاركان
نظيره الامريكي كما قالتنا المباحثات
تناولت التحديات الامنيه الاقليميه
وقال الفينتاجون ان رئيس هيئه الاركان
المشتركه الجنرال مارك ميلي بحث في تل
ابيب مع رئيس الاركان العامه الاسرائيليه
الفريق هيرسي التنسيق المشتركه لصد
التهديدات التي تشكلها ايران واضافها
الاسرائيلي ناقشا قضايا الامن الاقليمي
وفرص زياده التعاون الثنائك
وقال الجيش الاسرائيلي انه انها مناورات
بريه مشتركه مع قوات المارينز الامريكيه
واضفنا تلك المناورات تهدف لتعزيز التعاون
المشترك بين القوات البريه للجيشين كما
قال الجيش الاسرائيلي من المناورات شملت
لاول مره محاكاه التنسيق ضربه جويه
محتمله لمنشات نوويه نيرانيه
نقلت مجله الامريكيه عن مسؤولين امريكي
قوله ان حصول ايران على نظام الدفاع الجوي
اس 3 او اس 400 الروسيه الصنع سيساعد في
حمايه بنيتها التحتيه النوويه من ضربات
اسرائيليه محتمله
اجرى رئيس هيئه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
امسيه الجوله الاولى من المباحثات مع مدير
عام الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ياتي
هذا اللقاء بين الجانبين في طهران بعد نفي
ايران وتاكيد الوكاله الدوليه العثور على
جزيئات من اليورانيوم مخصبه بنسبه تزيد
على 80% اي اقل بقليل من 90% اللازمه
لانتاج قنبله النوويه
قال رئيس مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه
اصبحت محاصره بشكل شبهي كامل وان هناك
طريقا واحدا فقط لخروج القوات الاوكرانيه
من المدينه ودع بريكوجينا الرئيس
الاوكرانيه الى سحب قوته من المدينه في
اقرب وقت
اعلنا البيت الابيض عن حزمه مساعدات
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا من جانب اخر قال
الرئيس الامريكي وان الولايات المتحده
والمانيا تتحركان بخطى ثابته لتقديم
المساعده لاوكرانيا واضاف بعيدا خلال
استقباله المستشار الالماني ان برلين قدمت
دعما وفيرا لاوكرانيا
انتقد الرئيس الاوكراني ووصفه بتنازلات
لدول اوروبيه لم يسميها تجعل من الصعب
تحقيق نصر السريع لبلاده قال ان الروسي
يتجاوزون العقوبات ويساعدهم في ذلك دول
اعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي بحسب تعبيره
دعا الاتحاد التونسي للشغل الى مظاهرات
نحتجاجيه اليوم السبت وقال المتحدث باسم
الاتحاد ان الحكومه اغلقت ابواب المفاوضات
والحوار
في تعليق على مظاهرات اتحاد الشغل
المرتقبه قال الرئيس التونسيين الاتحاد حر
في تنظيم مظاهراته لكنه ليس حرا في دعوه
الاجانب للمشاركه فيها
هذا وقال الامين العام للامم المتحده في
مقابله مع الجزيره انه لابد من العمل من
اجل الحفاظ على الديمقراطيه في تونس واضاف
غوتيريشن انه لا ينبغي ان يعتقل اي شخص في
تونس على خلفيه رايه يا سياسي
اينما كنتم طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير